what we're going to try to do in this
video is approximate the area
under the curve y is equal to x squared
plus one between the intervals x is
equal or between the interval x equals
one and x equals three and we're going
to approximate it by constructing four
rectangles under the curve of equal
width so let's first think about what
those rectangles look like so four
rectangles of equal width
so look like that like that and like
that and i haven't really defined the
top of the rectangles just yet but let's
think about what those widths have to be
if they're going to be equal with and we
can call that with delta x so this
distance right over here we're going to
call that delta x so delta x is going to
have to be the total distance that we're
traveling in x so we finish at three we
started at one and we want four equal
width rectangles so it's going to be
equal to
one-half so for example this first this
first interval between the the boundary
between the first rectangle and the
second is going to be 1.5 then we go one
half to two then we go to 2.5
and then we go one half to three
now let's think about how we'll define
the height of the rectangles for the
sake of this video we'll see in future
videos that there's other ways of doing
this i'm going to use the left boundary
of the rectangle to define the height or
the function i should say i'm going to
use the function evaluated at the left
boundary to define the height so for
example for the first rectangle
this point right over here is f of 1
f of 1 and so i will say that that is
the height
of our first the height of our first
rectangle
then we go over here
the left boundary of the second
rectangle we're now looking at the
function evaluated the function
evaluated at 1.5 so that is f of 1.5
that's the height
and so we get our second rectangle
then we get i could keep going like this
we get for this third rectangle we have
the function evaluated at two
so we have the function evaluated at two
so that's right over here that's f of
two
and so then we get our third rectangle
and then finally we have our fourth
rectangle the function evaluated at 2.5
so the function evaluated at 2.5 is the
height so this is f of 2.5 remember in
each of these
i'm just looking at the left boundary of
the rectangle and evaluating the
function there to get the height of the
rectangle
now that i set it up in this way what is
the total approximate area using the sum
of these rectangles and clearly this
isn't going to be a perfect
approximation i'm giving up on a bunch
of area here let me see if i can color
that in with a color that i have not
used so i'm giving up i'm giving up this
area i'm giving up this area i'm giving
up that area i'm giving up that area
there but this is just an approximation
and maybe if i had many more rectangles
it would be a better it would be a
better approximation so let's figure out
what the areas of each of the rectangles
are so the area of this first rectangle
is going to be the height which is f of
f of 1 times the base which is delta x
the area of the second rectangle is
going to be the height which we already
said is f of 1.5
f of 1.5 times the base times delta x
the height of the third rectangle is
going to be the function evaluated its
left at its left boundary so f of 2
so plus f of 2 times the base times
delta x and then finally the area of the
third rectangle is the function the
height is a function evaluated at 2.5 so
plus that's a different color than what
i wanted to use
let me
i want to use that orange color so plus
the function evaluated at 2.5
times the base this is going to be equal
to our approximate area let me write
make it clear approximate
approximate
area under the curve just the sum of
these rectangles so let's evaluate this
so this is going to be equal to
f of is going to be equal to the
function evaluated at 1 1 squared plus 1
is just 2. so it's going to be 2
times 1 half
plus the function evaluated at 1.25 1.25
squared is 2.25
and then you add 1 to it it becomes 3.25
so plus
3.25 times one-half
times one-half
and then we have
the function evaluated at 2. well 2
squared plus 1 is 5. so it's 5
times one half
and then finally you have the function
evaluated at 2.5 2.5 squared is 6.25
times one-half
plus
or 6.25 plus one so that's 7.25
7.2
times one-half
and just to make the mat simpler we can
factor out the one-half so this is going
to be equal to all right one-half in a
neutral color one-half
times
one-half times two
plus three point two five
plus five
plus seven point two five
plus seven 7.25
which is equal to
one-half
one-half times let's see if i can do
this in my head two plus five is easy
that's seven three plus seven is ten and
then we have point two five plus 0.25 so
it's going to be
10.5 plus 7 is 17.5 so one half times
17.5 which is equal to
8.75 which once again gives us an
approximation clearly the way i've drawn
it right over here or the for the
function we're using it's going to be an
underestimate because we've given up all
of that pink area that i had colored in
before it's an underestimate but it's an
approximation of the area under the
curve in the next few videos we're going
to try to generalize this to situations
where we have an arbitrary function and
we have an arbitrary number of
rectangles and we'll also start and
videos after that we'll look at
rectangles where we define the height
not by the left boundary but by the
right boundary or by the midpoint or
maybe we don't use rectangles at all
maybe we might use things like
trapezoids anyway have fun